i want you to tell all your friends
about me where are you
i'm batman
there's been so many renditions of the
dark knight that i thought would be
interesting to look through some of the
different interpretations of batman
starting way back when and how he's
evolved to today's version
i'll attempt to use a broad range of
media that features batman including the
comics blockbuster movies and of course
the incredible
arkham game series also before we get
started i've had this idea to create
something like
a batman combat training guide as
something viewers can implement or add
to their own martial arts training
so if that's something you'd like to see
then please leave a comment below so
that i know you're interested
much of what we're going to analyze here
will correlate with the trends in an
improved interpretation of screen combat
as years
progressed with the whole of action
cinema in general arguably getting
better and then bringing with it an
increasing demand to provide better and
better action sequences
during this we'll analyze some of the
trends and techniques and strategies
that batman uses
in order to take down his numerous foes
but before that let's have a think about
the way batman may approach his training
in martial arts for his specific goals
according to the comics bruce's first
introduction to combat arts was his
experience learning boxing from ted
grant
a heavyweight boxer who acted secretly
as the hero wildcat so it could be said
that batman's base style is boxing we
know that at some time when he was a
teenager bruce left home to travel
around the world for roughly 10 to 15
years
at which time you learned a vast array
of skills including many different
martial arts
it's listed in various places that
batman is a master of 127 martial art
styles which i think is an old-school
comic book way of thinking about
cross-modality training like we see in
mma today
and practically it wouldn't be efficient
for batman to learn and master all
techniques from so many styles
arguably impossible but he is the batman
i'm batman
i found this quote that stated his
primary form of combat is an
idiosyncratic ab mix of taekwondo
judo muay thai karate boxing jiu jitsu
and ninjutsu and i would say looking at
the way batman moves this is pretty
accurate it's depicted in batman begins
that sometime during this period bruce
was trained by the league of shadows for
some say roughly a year or longer and by
the looks of the intensity and frequency
of his training with them this would
have led to his rapid improvement
if i were batman i'd be thinking about
the fastest and most effective ways to
take down multiple opponents and of
course
in general batman aims to be in actual
hand-to-hand combat situations as little
as he has to be
choosing instead to rely on his gadgets
and deception he would likely be looking
to draw the most effective techniques
from any martial arts style that he saw
fit
delivering blows with the force of a
professional fighter while also having
the grace and agility of an acrobat
which is no easy feat
batman's sheer size is a huge benefit to
him in this regard as well with his
height and weight being listed at six
foot two and 210 pounds so he's much
larger than the average man this means
he's naturally going to pack a lot of
stopping power into his strikes
although an investigation this is
relatively lean for somebody of that
height if we look at people like
muhammad ali for instance who was six
foot three was actually 235 pounds
so batman stats are that of a
heavyweight boxer but a relatively small
one which makes sense seeing as he needs
to have a good balance between having
big stopping power but also having high
level agility and gymnastic skills
so let's start then at the very
beginning of batman on screen
okay maybe not the very beginning
firstly we'll take a look at tim
burton's 1989 and 1991 renditions of the
batman in which he was played by michael
keaton
the use of the more technical martial
arts wasn't really present in these
movies and there was quite a lot of the
john wayne haymaker style attacks being
used
this is quite typical of the hollywood
style which had always been quite behind
in terms of its action compared to for
instance its eastern counterparts in
hong kong
however watching some behind the scenes
footage there were apparently massive
limitations with the costume and
multiple specialists had to be brought
in to do different elements with the
stunt work due to those limitations
it's been a long-running theme as well
that batman uses certain styles of
blocking due to the assistance provided
by his armored suit so we will often
block weapons using his forearms in a
tightly covered
position another benefit that comes into
play here is how batman will also use
the spikes that are on his arms which i
believe are known as fins
these are mainly used to catch and snap
weapons and can also fire as projectiles
as seen in the dark knight
so we do have some nice elements here
like this a bleak kick style block seen
in this clip this is a technique
originally derived from wing chun and
has been regularly used in professional
competition by mma fighter john jones
batman also uses a scythe kick regularly
which is pretty much the quintessential
martial arts kick and has been seen
throughout the batman mythology we do
see batman use a few grappling
techniques in these films like this
aikido-style wrist manipulation in which
he uses the momentum of the opponent's
incoming attack to redirect and control
him
and then ending this combination using a
throw later in the same
fight one element that i really did like
though that i'd never noticed before was
in batman returns in which we see this
jkd style
simultaneous defense encounter attack
happening that unless you look really
carefully you would completely miss
this reminds me of some parts in enter
the dragon in which we see bruce lee
doing some things that look really
simple but on closer inspection we can
see that he's doing a lot more
but you know if in doubt you can always
use a back fist
how could you i'm a woman
the next lot of movies were pretty
forgettable so i'll just breeze over
them quickly batman forever doesn't
really have anything memorable
or many fight scenes at all for that
matter so now moving on to batman and
robin
[Music]
let's just pretend this one never
happened moving swiftly on we're going
to focus on the christopher nolan
trilogy now
obviously there'd been a massive
improvement in filmmaking techniques
here since the 80s and 90s and i
personally think batman begins is the
best of the three films
nolan clearly wanted to betray batman in
a much more grounded way using
explanations such as depicting wayne
tech's applied sciences division being
behind batman's weapons arsenal and suit
this element of realism was also applied
to the action in the films but in my
opinion here's where it went just a bit
too far
in terms of making it realistic with the
almost sole inclusion
of using the casey fighting method kc
reflected quite nicely
on overall approach in terms of script
and design
seeing batman not as a glamorous sort of
branded figure
but as a functional entity as someone
who's a big martial arts as well as
batman fan i feel that the exclusion of
the less realistic moves in favor of the
close quarter stuff
took away from a lot of the
entertainment factor in terms of some of
the more fantastic kicks that we often
see batman using in other depictions the
kc method has elements that i think are
definitely things batman would use
especially against multiple opponents as
well as the tight guarding position
using the elbows as a realistic choice
for defensive protection but i would
have enjoyed to have seen some of the
more traditional martial art style kicks
thrown in here as well
the action is also very choppy and
batman begins in particular and we can
never really make sense of what's
happening which doesn't help enough to
making batman appear rigid at times and
not as dynamic
but again this may have been down to
costume limitations as batman begins
we're still using the old style of suit
technology that we saw in the previous
movies and that was until it was
replaced in the dark knight
speaking of which the shooting style in
terms of action changed quite
considerably in the dark knight and we
were able to see much more of what was
going on
making the action much more enjoyable i
really like certain elements like the
weapon break he uses
in this fight scene in the club and this
is something that we see being utilized
in the arc and video game series also
batman follows a common sense approach
when fighting multiple opponents with
his tendency being to firstly remove the
most immediate threat and then allowing
him to be in a much better position to
make his counter-attack afterwards with
the nature of taking on multiple
opponents in unpredictable environments
naturally he does get hit sometimes as
well but he intelligently utilizes the
damage that he takes to refocus and
assess what to do next
now there's one particular fight scene
in this movie that in my opinion is the
perfect depiction of batman in action
beating up thugs and using his gadgets
and surrounding environment to give him
an advantage
we also get a real sense of batman's raw
power with some of these massive blows
and ben affleck's sheer height and build
made his terrifying presence all the
more tangible but my favorite thing
about this scene is how fluid and agile
batman appears as he moves through his
opponents and just how well thought out
the scene is as a whole
no more of the stiff immobile neck
movement that we saw in the past he just
moves through the opponents decimating
them with devastating blows
again we see the theme of speed and
efficiency in this scene big time there
are just so many thugs in the warehouse
so it's imperative for batman to use a
strategy in which he can quickly
dismantle as many as possible before he
has no choice but to engage in
hand-to-hand combat so as we've seen in
previous depictions he uses his gadgets
as a starting point to take out some of
the thugs while startling others this
causes confusion among the group as to
his whereabouts he then further
capitalizes on this confusion and uses
that to get rid of a few more thugs at
this point the men realize where he is
and move into attack
batman uses techniques that are going to
take down his opponents as quickly as
possible which is essential for him not
to become overwhelmed
he commonly does this by using the
enemy's attack against them in whatever
shape that may take and then countering
it with an attack of his own relying on
his incredible reflexes and muscle
memory
then when there is a slight break in the
combat he will go on the offensive using
elements in the environment and his
gadgets to attack foes at a distance and
i just love the violence and lack of
mercy he displays to his opponents in
this scene the techniques he uses here
and many of the things we've seen before
we've got some heavy boxing some
headbutts
throws and also some nasty looking
breaks going on as well one thing they
did incorporate here was the use of some
tight elbows and knee strikes which work
perfectly for close quarter situations
in which he's not able to fully extend
his limbs
but the beauty of this scene is really
the way in which all of the elements are
seamlessly formulated together in an
exciting and entertaining manner
with the unlimited potential provided by
animation we see a batman similar to
that in dawn of justice but with a
little extra
including some of the more acrobatic
movements i'm not going to be able to
talk too much about all of the
individual techniques in the game as the
combat happens at such a pace that
before i can really stop to speak about
something there's already been about 200
subsequent techniques that have taken
place
because of the spaces in which the fight
scenes happen batman looks incredibly
although
unrealistically dynamic at times as he
dives around and glides between the
different foes but if you've played any
of the games you know that they are just
amazingly enjoyable
the combat has developed over the
different games and more and more has
been added with each installment one
thing that has remained constant
throughout
is the counter-attack ability in which
the player gets a brief warning to alert
them of approaching enemies depending on
which difficulty they're playing through
a prevalent feature in the game is how
the player must uniquely react
to the specific enemies they're fighting
as not all attacks work the same on all
enemies and some result in batman being
counter-attacked if the player uses the
wrong response
there's also many destructive elements
in the environment that can alter game
play at a moment's notice as well as
batman's ability to confuse enemies
using smoke grenades to limit their
vision and then attacking them using his
detective mode to give him the upper
hand i find this quite ingenious because
in a sense it actually makes the player
think like batman in combat
in terms of maintaining an awareness of
his environment at all times
even when engaged in combat with one or
more thugs with additions to gadgets and
combat technology one thing mentioned
earlier that has been seen
in various movies is the weapon
breakages a skill that becomes
unlockable the more wayne tech points
are accumulated i thoroughly enjoy the
beat down options personally
you can perform them generally against
any opponent but they're much more
prolonged and intricate when applied to
special foes and bosses when a number of
combo hits has been accumulated batman
unlocks the ability to perform special
moves in which the player presses a
combination of buttons together to take
an enemy down in one series of
predetermined movements
the way these look is different
depending on the enemy and situation but
generally involves a few powerful blows
followed by a throw of some kind or
wrestling move usually accumulating in a
knockout blow or limb break at the end
no discussion of the arkham series would
be complete without mentioning
the fear takedowns in which batman can
seamlessly tear through five foes in
succession once the ability is fully
unlocked the movements he uses here tend
to be pretty simple but due to the
element of surprise the attacks combine
with his pure focus of intent
batman is able to catch enemies off
guard giving him more time to land the
blows
in just the right place to take the
enemies down quickly you have to admit
that you feel pretty epic and powerful
when you successfully pull off a thea
takedown combo
in the end everyone loves and respects
me forever which is important
i could go on all day about the
different attacks in the games and we
didn't even get to mention things like
the endless fun that can be had with the
grapple and clothesline move that
admittedly i
massively overuse when playing the games
but if you've played them you'll know
all about this and no doubt have your
favorite go-to options
naturally the combat in arkham knight is
the best due to it being the most
current game in the series today due to
its refinement over the span of the
series
i also feel that the way the arkham
batman moves is the best portrayal of
batman in combat that we've seen over
any depictions today
so this video has been a look at batman
over the years and how his fighting
style has evolved
over some of the different media in
which he's appeared as mentioned earlier
if you guys enjoyed this video i'll look
at making something of a training guide
in the future depicting methods that you
can employ
in terms of martial arts training and so
on combine this with adam's incredible
already existing programmes on this
channel and you too
may be able to become the batman